Пункти попуску через лінію розмежування на Донбасі до пандемії коронавірусу...
...і нині.
Це - контрольний пункт в'їзду-виїзду - скорочено КПВВ - "Новотроїцьке".
З чотирьох пунктів пропуску у Донецькій області сьогодні він - єдиний, де можна перетнути лінію фронту.
З введенням карантинних обмежень та тих обмежень, що ввели представники
російської окупаційної влади, пасажиропотік впав з 12 тисяч осіб на добу до 200-300.
Також представниками російської окупаційної влади блокується пропуск громадян -
вони пускають людей лише по понеділках та п'ятницях.
На підконтрольному Україні боці "Новотроїцьке", як і всі інші КПВВ на Донбасі, відкритий щодня.
Натомість на окупованій території його роботу п'ять днів на тиждень блокує
влада квазіреспубліки "ДНР". Але навіть по понеділках та п'ятницях безперешкодно
виїхати з окупованого Донецька можуть лише ті, хто має прописку на підконтрольній уряду частині України.
Всі інші - лише за спеціальним дозволом окупаційної влади.
Я з Донецька, працював там, а зараз хочу сюди переїхати - в Україну.
Щоб виїхати з Донецька, потрібен дозвіл штабу із запобігання коронавірусній інфекції,
тобто запрошення на роботу або возз'єднання з родиною.
Ось я отримав запрошення на роботу і таким чином отримав дозвіл на виїзд,
а просто так виїхати не можна. Зібрав та подав документи, приблизно тиждень чекав на відповідь.
- DW: А тут що Вам треба зробити?
- Тут я просто роблю тест, якщо відповідь негативна - все, вільний.
Тест на коронавірус для людей, яким вдалося отримати дозвіл
та виїхати з окупованої території - безкоштовний.
Зробити його можна прямо на КПВВ.
Люди розповідають, що на КПП з боку сепаратистів умови геть інші.
DW: Тут як - більш цивілізовано, ніж там?
- Звичайно, набагато. Там, по-перше, тест зовсім інший. Там береться кров.
Таке приміщення в полі - засовуєш, вибачте, так руку у вікно, беруть кров і чекаєш.
Я, наприклад, чекала чотири з половиною години.
- DW: Скільки коштує?
- 1900 рублів. Тут безкоштовний.
Колишня донеччанка Анна живе у Маріуполі. У Донецьку відвідувала батьків.
Щоб потрапити у рідне місто, також мусила отримати спецдозвіл.
Набагато складніше стало. По-перше, щоб проїхати в Донецьк,
потрібно отримати спеціальний дозвіл у штабі в Донецьку.
Це все займає час - як мінімум сім днів. Плюс на пунктах пропуску дуже ретельна перевірка,
аж до особистого огляду - в Донецьку, там, в ДНР.
- Що за штаб?
- У Донецьку існує штаб, називається штаб "Здоровий рух", з протидії поширенню коронавірусної інфекції.
Ось туди потрібно подавати документи, і вони вже їх розглядають
і дають свій дозвіл або відмовляють у в'їзді або виїзді з Донецька.
Мешканці окупованих територій, яким влада ДНР виїхати не дозволяє та ті,
хто не може або просто не хочете чекати на дозвіл від сепаратистів, їдуть через Росію.
Це - незаконно, адже автобуси перетинають українсько-російський кордон на ділянці,
яку контролюють бойовики. Дорога з окупованої Горлівки у вільний Краматорськ,
що знаходиться лише за сто кілометрів від неї, через Росію триває близько 15 годин.
А на в'їзді в Україну на подорожуючих чекає штраф за незаконний перетин кордону - 1750 гривень.
- Десь від 12 до 15 годин. Взагалі як би ми беремо 2800,
а щодо штрафу - адвокату ми платимо 600 гривень з нашої кишені і адвокат всі ці питання вирішує.
Він офіційно оскаржить штраф у суді.
Ділки навіть пропонують вирішити питання із тестом на коронавірус
- він необхідний, щоб уникнути самоізоляції після перетину кордону.
Ми допомагаємо зробити тест - він коштує 600 гривень.
Справа в чому: ми приїжджаємо в Артемівськ, робимо тест, 20 хвилин - і все знято.
- Ну, ви розумієте, що за 20 хвилин жодні тести не робляться. Розумієте? Це чиста формальність.
Така довга та нелегальна дорога для багатьох мешканців окупованої території -
єдиний шлях, щоб побачити рідних, допоки бойовики блокують роботу офіційних КПВВ.
Обмеження на в'їзд та виїзд окупаційна влада пояснює складною ситуацією з коронавірусом в Україні.
Натомість правозахисники переконані - справжня причина інша.
Обмеження введені штучно - саме для того, щоб люди, які мешкають на окупованих територіях,
не бачили позитивних змін, які відбуваються на контрольованій частині
Луганської та Донецької областей.
Будуються дороги, будується інфраструктура, будуються зручні сервісні центри,
де люди з окупованих територій можуть отримати адміністративні
та ще низку важливих для них послуг.
Російська сторона зараз взагалі не налаштована на покращення гуманітарної ситуації
та на посилення, фактично відновлення зв'язків між українцями,
які живуть на окупованих і вільних територіях Донбасу.
Підтвердженням того, що підконтрольні Росії квазіреспубліки прагнуть ізолювати людей,
які залишились на окупованій території, також є блокування ними роботи КПВВ
у містах Золоте та Щастя у Луганській області. Ці пропускні пункти давно відкриті з українського боку.
Утім, скористатися ними не можливо.
Адже так звана "ЛНР" свої КПП на цих напрямках не відкриває,
щоразу вигадуючи нові приводи.